THINKS IT'S OKAY TO CLIP THEIR
TOENAILS?
AND THAT IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
BEST THINGS, HERE IS JEANNE
MOOS.
>> Reporter: PASSENGERS, PREPARE
FOR SHAMING ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
NOT IN THE UPRIGHT POSITION AND
YOUR FEET ARE ON YOUR TRAY
TABLE.
>> IT IS SO BEYOND YIKES.
>> Reporter: FORMER FLIGHT
ATTENDANT CREATED A FACEBOOK
PAGE SHOWCASING PASSENGERS
BEHAVING BADLY, LEAVING DIRTY
DIAPERS AND GOING SHIRTLESS.
HOW FAR WE'VE CHANGED FROM THE
OLD DAYS.
INSTEAD OF PEARLS, CHECK OUT THE
ALTITUDE OF THESE SHORTS.
>> IT IS GETTING WORSE BY THE
MINUTE.
>> Reporter: HER PERSONAL PET
PEEVE?
>> SOCKS STAY ON.
>> Reporter: SURE IT IS FUNNY
WHEN JOHN CANDY DOES IT IN THE
MOVIE.
>> OH, MY DOGS ARE BARKING
TODAY.
>> Reporter: BUT WHO WANTS TO
LET BARKING DOGS LIE WHEN THEY
INTRUDE FROM ANOTHER ROW?
WE RECOMMEND KEEPING YOUR FEET
COVERED AND YOUR HANDS EXPOSED.
HOW GROSS IS IT TO SEE A GUY
SLEEPING WITH HIS HANDS DOWN HIS
-- AVERT YOUR EYES.
ONE PASSENGER?
>> HE CAUGHT HIS HAIR ON FIRE IN
THE BATHROOM HAD WHEN HE WAS
SMOKING CRACK.
>> Reporter: WHY DON'T YOU SKIP
THE IN-FLIGHT MANICURE?
NOBODY WANTS TO SEE YOU TREAT
YOUR FEET AT 30,000 FEET.
>> THERE WAS ONE MAN CLIPPING
HIS FEET.
>> Reporter: SHE CHANGED HER JOB
TO A NURSE PRACTITIONER.
SOMEHOW LOOKING AT THIS?
SEEMS WORSE, A PASSENGER USING A
PILLOW CASE TO COVER HIS EYES
WHILE UNCOVERING THE REST.
>> COME FLY WITH ME, LET'S FLY.
>> Reporter: SURE, LET'S FLY,
BUT DON'T LEAVE BEHIND YOUR
BOXERS, YOUR